okay so Adam is back with this second
talk all right great
all right thanks thanks for your
attention so okay so in the second part
of the talk so okay so but what did we
see in kind of the first part of the
talk what we did is we talked about the
complexity theoretic foundations
really of the boson sampling experiment
and what did we conclude let's well we
should said something like well you need
to make some average case approximate
hardness conjecture but we don't know
how to prove this you know so but we're
able to support it by giving kind of
average case exact hardness statements
and worst case approximate statements
okay and kind of what happened in after
an errant Sun arkhipov wrote their paper
in 22 2010 2011 was this kind of
launched the experimental quest for
supremacy so a huge number of optical
groups went out and they tried to
perform the boson sampling experiment
and they made you know some serious
progress here so I think as as of a few
years ago the largest experiment they
did though involve something like six
bosons though more recently the pan
group made a substantial progress at and
performed boson sampling but something
like 14 bosons that they could reliably
get but this is still kind of this is
still out of the range of classical
intractability so if you are at estimate
the number of bosons you need to do a
boson sampling experiment that you know
you couldn't say simulate on your laptop
or something you would need let's say 40
or 50 plus bosons so this this boson
sampling experiment had really great
complexity theoretic evidence for
hardness you know would within within
kind of the abilities of mathematics but
you know it just wasn't yet experimental
be feasible so what happened in
intervening years is that there was
serious progress in superconducting
qubits by the Google UCSB group and many
other groups around the world so what
happened was the Google UCSB group okay
but the problem is their architecture
doesn't natively do boson sampling like
their architecture
she's different than linear optical
framework it could technically simulate
the boson sent an experiment but with
some overheads are just prohibitively
hard when you have these really tiny
machines so what happened was that the
Google UCSB group in the paper by boy
shell out in 2016 they showed what they
did is they defined kind of the
superconducting qubit analog analog
who's on sampling or their particular
device okay and so what is the analog
version of Busan sampling well it's
something called random circuit sampling
so what's the basic idea the basic idea
is you fix some architecture on qubit
based quantum circuit so I could say I'm
going to apply a gate here then the gate
here then the gate here and then measure
so these are my inputs and the basic
idea is the distribution over circuits
they defined was basically to pick each
gate of the circuit from iid from the
HAR measure
so the hard measure here on you know
this is just you know quantum gates are
continuous on like classical gates so
this is just the notion of what is a
truly random gate so the test that they
define was to pick each gate of circuit
randomly this is their distribution of
their circuits and you know then sample
from the corresponding probabilities
distribution
and what they did is they conjectured
that this task is classically
intractable okay so so that's great so
if your so now as we saw from the
framework from last time and we have
this very general machine to take a
hardness of sampling conjecture and turn
it into a hardness of computing
conjecture so they made this exact same
conjecture for the random circuit
sampling experiment let's defined
exactly as it was in Bill's on sampling
you just conjecture that it's hard to
compute the output probabilities of
random quantum circuits this is the on
average statement approximately there
within some amount of error and if you
yes yes exactly yeah
so that's a great question so it's yeah
so actually they actually proposed doing
this for a very particular architecture
so by an architecture I mean like how
are your qubits laid out and where are
you going to apply the gates and and how
much depth so they particularly proposed
that for a 2d architecture so it's like
a grid of root n by root n qubits and
the depth actually order root n that was
the very concrete proposal but you know
you can define random circuit sampling
like this is a much more general
definition you can fill in any
architecture you like into the
definition and actually many of the
results I'll be talking about will be
agnostic largely agnostic about this
this choice of okay so yeah so it's true
so yeah to formally define this problem
you have to pick this architecture as
well if you do this and make this
following kind of magical conjecture
then you can conclude that it's it's
hard to approximately sample from this
distribution in the average case this is
just just what we saw last time
but now the okay so now this proposal
had one thing going for it which it did
not provably have in the boson sampling
case RCS had some has an additional
property that's called anti
concentration which is called anti
concentration so what is anti
concentration it's basically the
statement that on average on average
over the choice of C this output
probability p0 c is relatively large
like it's it's roughly what you would
expect it to be 1 over 2 to the n all
right and what this means the
implication for this is that our
additive errors in the conjecture in the
conjecture are actually multiplicative
errors
so you can see that says it's sometimes
saying that you know once you have some
some form of average-case hardness you
know you know that error is that you're
trying to incorporate you know are
smaller than the signal you're looking
for so that's the saying like that the
noise is small relative to the signal I
mean just from numerix we're almost
certain that that holds for bosons -
yeah that's exactly yeah exactly yeah
Scott points out boson sampling no one
has been able to prove this but yeah but
the numerix very very strongly support
this and similarly when google wrote
this paper they had numerix to justify
this but was recently proven by heroine
mara bond in 2019 that these circuits of
you know 2d grid circuits of death
through then actually do anti
concentrate extending work of bran Dale
Garrow and and horrid s key from from a
few years ago okay so that's great so
what does that mean so if we are to make
a kind of chart of the different
properties that your experiment could
have
you know there's some things you know
let's let's fill in I'm just going to
kind of copy this chart here so this is
worst-case approximate hardness this is
average case exact this is an average
case approximate and this is anti
concentration which is something that
makes their approximate average case
conjecture a little more believable so
if we looked at the status of boson
sampling you know we have worst case of
practice with the hardness average case
exact hardness you know we don't know
that spot but we have numerical evidence
and you know this is the chart that's
going to be open for every proposal we
and in fact there were more proposals
than this that had kind of this kind of
picture like there's also a proposal
called Fourier sampling from in humans
that had this exact same status okay but
great so now we're weirded random
circuit sampling fall in here well let's
say random circuit sampling we know this
a profitless worst case average case
hardness so this this is like the the
freebie and we have this anti
concentration okay as you might suspect
we don't have average case approximate
hardness for here too but our CS was
missing some some evidence that boson
sampling had mainly it was missing any
notion of average case exact hardness
okay so if you were to look at the
status of our CS and compare it to booth
on sampling this this was what the
picture was as of 2016 when they made
this proposal alright and this is I as a
complexity theorist this felt a little
bit worrisome are kind of begging some
question just because you know you're in
some sense average case hardness is all
about finding a distribution that you
think is hard like this is the key you
know to establishing say cryptographic
hardness
and if you don't have any kind of
average case exact hardness for random
surrogate sampling then it's not that
clear why you should be conjecturing
average case approximate hardness
because you don't even know there's any
average case hardness in your
distribution whatsoever right so you in
fact you might worry that somehow this
distribution over random circuits has
some additional structure that that
makes this problem actually much easier
much in the same way that you know when
you pick distributions over 3sat there
are some distributions that become very
easy even though in the worst case you
know it's it's extremely hard so yeah so
this was the status of the proposal and
moreover if you look at this you notice
that none of the proposals had
average-case exact hardness and anti
concentration simultaneously maybe you
kind of worried that these could have
somehow been in tension with one another
and well because you know as I mentioned
that boson sampling had this this kind
of picture there were other supremacy
proposals that had these same properties
of RCS as well so for instance there is
an i QP proposal an average case version
of brendham m there month in their own
shepard that has this exact same kind of
pattern of checks in terms of you know
where where we have proofs and and kind
of where we're missing evidence so so
the next thing i'd like to tell you
about is in about some recent work and
this is my joint work with bill
pfefferman chin minor-key and mush balls
irani and in this work what we showed is
we showed that we filled in this box
we're in the circuits and we
so in particular what we showed as we
share the form of exact average case
hardness or computing average case
output probabilities P naught of C or C
drawn from this distribution so in other
words this provided kind of strong
complexity theory support to to the
random circuit sampling experiment so it
now kind of has the same level of
complexity theory X support as the boson
sampling experiment but moreover we're
able you know there's a rigorous proof
of this anti concentration property
while filling in credit Eretz arkhipov
also here so
okay so you can now see that what what
this kind of work did it brought RCS
kind of up to the forefront the best we
can do from as complexity theorists in
order to justify these experiments so
far so yeah so now the story of how you
prove this is very interesting so in the
next say ten or fifteen minutes I'm
going to give you a proof sketch of how
you actually prove this exact average
case hardness result and the proof is
very interesting you can see it as
extending some very classic work of
Lipton from the 90s which era Tanaka
Popeye extended to their case but there
are lot of twists and turns that come up
along the way in order to make this work
for quantum circuits which have a very
different structure than the sort of
permanence that were previously argued
about so let me explain a little bit
what I mean so let's recall the
definition of the permanent so the
permanent have a matrix a let's say a is
let's start with the finite field case
the part of the matrix a is given by the
following exponential sub u sum over all
permutations in SN and then you consider
taking the product of a i sigma of i
from i equals 1 to n so let me just
write another formula for you you know
you're probably more familiar with the
determinant which is the exact same
quantity but where you add in the sign
of Sigma into the son now it turns out
that there's a very huge difference in
the complexities of computing
determinants versus permanence so
particular computing the permanent of a
a sharpie hard and in the worst case and
moreover there's this classic result of
Lipton which says it's also hard on
average okay and so I'm going to explain
to you this lift and proof now just
because it's I think it's really like a
proof from the book in terms of it being
very elegant and we're going to try to
copy that over to the quantum circuit
case and then what kind of see that a
lot of things go go wrong all right so
let's Lorelei's by what we mean it's
hard on the average well what we're
going to do in order to prove this is
we're going to perform a worst case the
average case reduction right so what
does that mean like let's say you're
given some matrix a which is possibly
worst case let's talk about the finite
field case and you're also given the
ability like some algorithm to compute
the permanent of random matrices are
with some high probability as to say
with high probability over the choice of
R where R is a uniformly random element
of F Q to the N by M and the goal is to
compute the permanent of a using this
test alright so you can see that if
we're able to to prove that this goal as
possible this implies computing the
permanent is hard on average because we
know that computing permanent a in the
worst case is hard so if we're able to
reduce it to the problem of computing
random permanence then then we'll know
that actually computing these permanence
on average is also a difficult task as
well okay now how do we do this well
this proof is it's really interesting
you know at first glance if you look at
that formula and you look at that goal
it kind of looks hopeless right because
these random matrices are whose
permanence that you can compute have
nothing to do with this just worst-case
matrix a
so you know huh how do you even get
started here right but the key here to
proving average-case hardness ends up
being in trying to find some sort of
structure in the problem that gives you
the ability to infer worst casing
permanence from average-case tournaments
and in this case the structure that we
find as a much of classical theoretical
computer science is a low degree
polynomial structure so the basic idea
the you know Lipton's proof looks
something like this so I'm going to find
a family of matrices I'm going to pick a
matrix R uniformly from F Q to the N by
n I'm going to define a univariate line
of matrices a of T which is equal to our
matrix a plus T times R ok so let's
assume that the finite field size is
sufficiently large here
all right so what's interesting about
this univariate line well it has a few
properties the first is that a of zero
oh sorry she mentioned T's in the finite
field two so what's the first property
of this line
well a of 0 is equal to a mean all right
that's kind of the first property ok
it's nice and simple all right the
second property is the structure of
property and this is that it turns out
that the permanent of a of T is a degree
n polynomial in the variable T all right
why is that well you just kind of look
at the definition if each entry of a is
a univariate polynomial T which is this
in this line then the product of the
entries here is this is a polynomial of
degree n so the sum of polynomials of
degree n is another polynomial of degree
n so this I'm going to call the
polynomial property because this is a
property that gives structure to the
problem ok but this line actually has in
this univariate line actually has
another property here that's maybe even
a little more slick and that is a
property that I'm going to call the
marginal property the marginal property
says the following thing if you pick any
T which is nonzero then the distribution
of a of T is distributed uniformly in fq
to the N by M so what is this saying
well you define this univariate line and
this matrix R it's kind of serving as a
one-time pad right and it's saying that
if you were to look at any individual
element of the line it would just look
uniformly random but actually if you
looked at several of them at once you
know they wouldn't be independently
uniformly random they're each actually
correlated with one another hugely but
you can deduce R by L so subtracting two
adjacent ones but the marginal is is
there so what this marginal property
means is that let's say that your
algorithm here
computes this permit 'var with
probability more than one minus epsilon
well if we were to just look at one of
these individual a of T this means that
your algorithm actually would compute a
of T with probability more than one
minus Epsilon right because that's you
know this marginal profit this
distribution on inputs is exactly the
distribution that we know how to compute
on average so great so how are we going
to use this to perform the worse the
average case reduction
well we're going to use a nice trick the
basic idea is we're going to pick some
various values of T let's just pick them
1 2 3 up to n plus 1 and ask our average
case algorithm to compute each one the
clever thing that you can do now is you
can invoke a Union bound so the trick is
something like this by the Union bound
remember the Union bound doesn't care
about correlations the probability that
all that you compute all of these AFI
all of these aft correctly this is more
than 1 minus epsilon times n plus 1
right the reason is if you have you know
some events each one of them fails with
probability Epsilon
well n of them fail was probability at
most any one of them fails was
probability at most n times 1 minus
epsilon independent of of how they're
correlated with one another great so
what this means is if you just set
epsilon such that this is more than
two-thirds this means that so let's say
epsilon is 1 over poly then this means
that by this you need bound you will
actually have been able to compute all
of these all of these values correctly
you got everyone correct and you can now
probably see the end of the proof you
call this polynomial P of T which is the
permanent of AF T that means that this
means that you know by polynomial
interpolation this actually fixes a ft-
fixes P of T so now all you do is you
compute this polynomial so now you
compute P of 0 and this is the permanent
of a alright so this proof is I think
really beautiful because it's kind of
carefully balancing these two properties
one property that's this kind of
structure property and this polynomial
property another property is this
marginal property which is saying that
within the structure you can still make
things look random there's actually kind
of some intrinsic tension between these
two properties
and when we try to port this over to
random circuit sampling this tension is
going to come out in full force yes I
see your question
what happens if q it's not large that's
a that's a great question I don't think
I'm not yeah I'm not sure off the top of
my head that if hardness is no but I
will mention that if Q is is
sufficiently large polynomial e large
there are much more sophisticated
versions of this proof using list
decoding and various tricks that
actually say not only is permanent hard
to compute with probability 1 minus
Polly it's even hard to compute with
probability 1 over Polly like there's no
algorithm that even gets some tiny
fraction of permanence correct so yeah
but but they're the large field size is
critical again this doesn't work for Q
is 2 oh yes yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a
good put yes great great point yeah cute
let's do this is permanent its
determinant so yeah that's that's a good
question you know off the top of your
head just be vacuous because the problem
is easy exactly
oh no it doesn't you need it more than T
plus 1 you needs to be more than n plus
1 for this to work always compute is
known to be intractable for that case
but I think the right thing to say is
acute is 3 you just need a new idea much
more than what's being discussed for for
small values of Q
great great thanks alright so now uh
great so that's great that's how you
establish average case hardness and
Ayrton arkhipov extended this time from
this finite field setting to the case of
Gaussian random matrices which is moving
to the complex field well in the case of
random circuit sampling we have a
different problem so let's try the port
that's over two RCS and see what happens
so how do we prove average case hardness
for RC yes we have the exact same set up
we're given some circuit C and the
ability to compute zero of random
circuits R where R is drawn from this
distribution over circuits where you
pick each gate iid randomly and our goal
is to compute P not of C okay so let's
let's start looking at where we can draw
similarities with the permanent well the
first thing that we can note is that
there is a low degree polynomial
structure hiding in form of circuits the
count of polynomial structure is that
this problem output probability P now C
is actually a degree M polynomial in the
gate entries of the circuit
so in plum circuits have real gate
entries or sorry or complex gate entries
and if you consider those great gate
entries it's variable it turns out that
Pima of C does have the slow degree
polynomial property this is by the
Fineman path integral of view of form
service ok great so now how can we make
use of this well ok let let let's try
the copy Lipton's proof well what
happens all right so let's take our
worst case circuit C and let's consider
some circuits C of T which is C plus T
times a random circuit C all right so
what's what's wrong here well there's
like there's like a type error here
right so the unitary group is not a
linear subspace so you can't take two
quantum circuits and add them together
right actually the structure here you
know the structure is the structure of a
continuously group it's not a linear
subspace as it wasn't permanent ok so
that's a little annoying so let's let
but you know what let's see you see if
we can work with that let's let's try to
take let's try to do something like this
let's define some circuit C prime which
is we take our worst-case circuit C and
multiply it by our random randomly
chosen circuit R and here my right this
I mean like gate wise multiplication so
by the haar measure this C prime is
uniformly distributed
it's you porting the you know
distributed in the unitary group so this
has the marginal property but it's
missing a parameter for us to bury right
leg it's missing a teeth you mean
composition or like they have the same
structure and then the coefficients of
each Gator I mean they have the same
structure so and and you just multiply
each gate separately so if I were
multiplying like this circuit by this
circuit this where a and B and I were
multiplying this with C and D then this
thing would be equal to a circuit which
is C times a and circuit which is d
times B does that make sense because I
this is you can also just say just look
at what happens on each individual gate
and you'll have the same story so this
is okay great so we need some way okay
so okay we found the marginal property
in the polynomial property separately
now we need some way of combining them
to get them at the same time okay so
let's let let's try to do something
uniquely clock them and let's try to use
them the uniquely quality that you can
implement a fraction of a gate in
quantum mechanics so what do I mean by
that so let's take a random gate our
from the harm measure and let me define
a new gate R of theta this will be R
times a theta
amount of the inverse of R so this is e
to the minus I log
times okay I can might as well call it
peace events a little more similarity
just just playing e to the I log RT why
oh sure sure yeah yeah but why yeah so
why rotate all the way and be back well
I just wanted to have some analogy
so I'm now defined C of T to the C times
this product with R of T and now I want
the property that C of 0 is this is just
a convention so set C of 0 is my worst
case circuit and 0 as my favorite points
right actually Oh No see you know
actually now I've made C or 0 random I
made C of 1 see ya this is just a
convention ok great so what did we do we
basically took our worst case circuit
we've totally scrambled it and then we
like dialed it a little bit back towards
our worst case circuit like we just took
some knob and we tuned it a little bit
and you can show that C of T for small T
is marginally is distributed on the
margin close in total variation distance
see the heart measure great so we found
our marginal property that's great so
we're done right well no there's
actually still a problem right what's
what's the the problem as we did this
and we lost the polynomial property
right what what why is this true this is
because e to the IH T is not you know a
low degree polynomial in T it's actually
a polynomial of infinite degree okay so
we we got our marginal property and our
univariate path but then we lost our
polynomial property which is the
structure gluing it all together okay
all right great so let's let's just
solve this again so what what's the
obvious thing to do well you know if
you're a physicist and you see e to the
IH T the thing you have to do is take a
Taylor series approximation to it that's
that's what everyone does so let's let
let's take a Taylor series of each of
IHT let's define that and then this so
now you regain you regain your
polynomial property and moreover this
you know you're pretty but because
Taylor series are so good this output
probability of the truncated circuit is
extremely close to the probability of
the original one but now you have this
problem that you lost the marginal
property again so this is actually a
very annoying technicality but kind of
what our main contribution was is we
actually showed that basically that's
okay so in the bf in the work of in my
joint work with with bill and shin myeon
mesh well we showed this that this kind
of result still has the same
interpretation in terms of average in
terms of supremacy as it does in the as
it does if we had done it with if we had
recovered the marginal property as well
and the basic reason is something like
this you know think about your average
case approximate hardness conjecture
you're trying to conjecture that's hard
to get out for the number peanuts e-type
anywhere in some big interval like
you're trying to say it's hard to get
anywhere in the interval of one over two
to the n Polly event this is we want
kind of you know throwing a dart
anywhere in this interval to be a hard
problem well what we did is by doing our
truncation we found another point right
next to it that's hard so let's call
this P prime not FC this is the this is
what occurs after the truncation so what
we showed is that computing this point
is hard but you know you can clearly see
this as necessary for the average case
approximate hardness conjecture because
if you think the whole interval hard is
hard then of course you know getting
some particular points in the interval
is hard and moreover if you could
improve the approximation robustness of
this then it would cover the whole
interval as well so there's some sense
in which if you improved our robustness
results then this would cover the whole
thing oh yes but there there's closeness
and total variation distance and we
don't have that but in case you're
worried about this let me quickly give a
shout out there is a subsequent paper of
muga SOG nineteen which showed that by
choosing a different path you can
recover both properties simultaneously
so therefore MOBA socks result then
shows that actually indeed computing
this point at the center hold of the
interval is actually hard as well so in
case you are worried this was like a
fundamental issue with the proof then
this there is that this has actually
been fixed yes yeah that's correct so
the last time yeah so on the last talk I
kind of explained that there's a
reduction from hardness of sampling I
yeah there's a reduction that shows if
you have a sampler then you can estimate
most output probabilities and therefore
if you conjecture estimating most output
probabilities is very hard then you get
the non-existence of a sampler as well
yes on average there yeah this is an
average case statement so then this is
now trying to provide kind of
justification as to why you might
believe this average case statement that
estimating this output probability
anywhere in this window is hard and the
evidence that we're giving is well we at
least know there's some points in this
interval that are hard but we just don't
know how to extend that via by our
techniques and the reason that it seems
really hard to improve the robustness of
this results is that what we're
effectively doing in this proof is a
form of like polynomial extrapolation
and polynomial extrapolation there's
just very ill condition so this is
basically the limitation as to why it's
difficult to prove robustness results in
this area
and when you do to truncation don't you
reduce unitarity
yes that's right that's why you lose the
marginal property precisely yep but yeah
but again this subsequent work of move a
song shows you can actually get both of
these at once if you pick your path more
cleverly okay great so that's
essentially the status of the Google
supremacy experiment if you just look at
it in terms of evidence of hardness well
not entirely as I'll describe shortly
but that's the status in terms of
justifying it in terms of this these
arguments with sharp peak right like
we're able to recover this average case
exact hardness we still have to
conjecture average case approximate
hardness but there is a lot left to do
that kind of try to ask is this
approximate average case hardness
conjecture to true so in the next part
of my talk I'm going to switch gears
with my remaining time I'm going to tell
you about the problem of verification of
these of this experiments and the
problem of verification is is quite
challenging and it involves a kind of
completely different line of reasoning
than we've been pursuing to try to get
evidence of hardness so what's the
problem with verification well as we
already pointed out you know we're
trying to verify a sampling problem so
we want to check
that the devices output probability
distribution let me call this the
experimental distribution is closed
until the variation distance to the
ideal distribution this is our goal but
the problem is that you know if you were
to do kind of naive sampling to
characterize to completely characterize
this exponet this experimental
distribution this will need an
exponential number of samples
Lauro barone also need an exponential
amount of processing time
that's because you would as tomorrow
that at the in this question last talk
like you would also need to you know
kind of compute what the ideal
distribution should be with your
classical computer and and that that
seems very challenging so the compromise
that's been made has been to try to
think of this in kind of a a Goldilocks
regime where okay so what if I just gave
you only polynomially many samples form
device but instead I still allowed you
exponential post processing time on the
classical supercomputer
so this is a small number of samples you
know you can't actually characterize
your distribution but you you are giving
yourself some power you're giving
yourself a big supercomputer and if you
pick a small enough value of n like n is
like 40 or 50 you know maybe you can
squeeze this computation on to some
giant cluster and performs you know some
sort of computation of ideal output
probabilities on your device of course
this is something that won't scale to N
equals 100 cubits or two hundred cubits
well it's something that you can do with
these particular finite size experiments
so what was the proposal
so the proposal was to use these samples
and this was the proposal of Butch show
at all their proposal was to use the
small number of samples to compute some
very core statistical score of their
output distribution what was the score
the score was they could said said what
happens if you compute the cross entropy
between the experiments distribution and
the ideal distribution right let's
recall the cross entropy is the thing it
looks just like the entropy but the
probability one of the probabilities
comes from one distribution and the
other probability comes from the other
distribution now the interesting point
about cross entropy is you can rewrite
it as an expectation value this is an
expectation value of if you draw X from
the experimental distribution of the log
of one over the ideal distribution and
it turns out that this is very helpful
so because this is an expectation value
this actually turns out that you can
estimate it very efficiently with very
few samples from the device
an SMA cross-entropy very well but only
polynomially many samples from device
but note that estimating it requires you
still using your classical supercomputer
right because but the way that you
empirically estimate this is you just
draw some samples from your device you
kind of press the button get a few
strings X but then you have to go with
your classical supercomputer and compute
its ideal output probability in the
circuit if you had done everything
perfectly
so this actually requires a hard
computation but the fact that this
converges quickly this is actually a
special property of the output
distributions of these circuits if
you're in case you're wondering what's
happening here these output if you look
at the output probabilities of these
circuits they tend to be concentrated
they have a very particular structure
called the porter Thomas distribution
and this means that the logs of the logs
are there the output probabilities are
on average multiplicatively bounded and
this means that you know the expectation
of multiplicatively bounded quantities
converges okay so yes yeah great
question so Google ended up using a
linear version of this but actually they
computed this was their original
proposal was to use the cross entropy so
so what Google actually computed they
call that the linear cross entropy or
something like this and it's the same
thing but you don't take the log so it's
just DX the it'd so this is just like
the inner product between the
distributions
but this version is less sensitive yeah
yeah so yeah I'll get to that when I
explain their experiment but the but
basically they're yeah but but basically
that was just so that they could get
like a better confidence in their whole
and their value for us it turns out that
it's actually and some if you're looking
at you know actual concrete numbers it
was easier for them they got a bigger
confidence in their vote to get higher
confidence and their XE value so their
Cu value but they actually compute the
CEO and their supplementary materials
it's it's the same okay so great so
that's a proposal across that repeat its
natural question to ask you know is this
at all connected with the complexity
theoretic hard evidence of hardness
sorry I should say maybe what what what
their proposal was I should have written
this verse so what they're actually
proposal was was to take their device
and they wanted to achieve some
cross-entropy value which is equal to
the ideal value minus epsilon so their
actual proposal was basically to perform
this experiment they know what they
should be getting ideally for this
course statistical score like let's
normalize it such that is that such that
if they are outputting the uniform
distribution they get zero if they do
something perfect they get the one you
can normalize it by kind of subtracting
and an appropriate correction factor and
what they conjectured is that I'm you
know if they did their experiment and
they got you know sufficiently close to
one then this is a demonstration of
qualm supremacy because they've actually
demonstrated they've they've done some
hurt computation so it's natural to ask
I've to what sense does this hold does
in what sense does this hold water and
to what extent you know does this
connect with our complexity theory
evidence for hardness which was all
about not about the score but was about
total variation distance okay so the
interesting result is that it actually
does rigorously connect in some regimes
but not in others so in particular in
this joint work with government they're
keen bus irani what we end up showing is
that under some conditions
having a cross entropy of you know 1
minus epsilon implies closeness until
the variation distance so some amount
which ends up being order root epsilon
and the relevant condition is that the
entropy of the experimental distribution
is greater than the entropy of the ideal
distribution so if you have a form of
quantum noise that's kind of pumping
entropy into your device then actually
if you get a really good process entropy
score you actually have shown that
you're close until the variation
distance and as an example like if you
have depolarizing noise the polarizing
noise is essentially kind of taking your
qubit and replacing it with a random
coin flip so this is your qubit going to
0 1 with 50/50 probability then it does
satisfy this this condition oh there are
other types of noise that don't satisfy
this condition so but we also proved
another statement which is also that
there exists distributions of lower
entropy
than the ideal that fool cross-entropy
in other words they get cross-entropy
score of one but they're very far in the
total variation distance battery now the
interesting thing is that you know we
had to drop the entropy of the
distribution in order to get this
counter example and the and there
actually are some ports of noise that
could decrease entropy some noise could
decrease the entropy
so an example of that type of noise is
amplitude damping noise I don't know if
there's a proof that this happened but
maybe it's more that there's a worry
that it could happen
which is basically if you take your
qubit and you replace it with zero so
this is like the polarizing noise but
it's it has a direction instead of being
like an unbiased type of noise it's a
bias type of noise it's it's driving you
towards zero you can think of this as
kind of like resetting your quantum
circuit a little bit that each step back
to the initial state and the thing is
the entropy of this distribution partly
comes from maintaining kind of coherence
the whole way out so you might worry
that if you get reset later on you you
might not end up having as much entropy
in this room so what's kind of the
lesson here is that their supremacy
claim kind of rests on two things like
you both need to check the score that's
kind of the obvious thing to look at and
you need to look at the noise that they
were president device their device you
know has a very complicated noise Tower
I think it's something that's extremely
hard to characterize experimentally it
probably has some depolarizing noise
some amplitude damping noise crosstalk
or all sorts of weird things going on
the device but there's a question of is
it actually increasing the entropy of
the distribution the annoying thing is
this is not something you can check
efficiently because estimating entropy
of a distribution on exponentially an
exponential size domain takes
exponential samples so this is something
that I think there's a lot of
interesting work to be done to try to
characterize what's happening in your
device
all right great so you've now seen the
the theory of verification and the
hardness let's talk about what Google
actually did
so love with Google's result I know UCSB
a different marker since this
what they did is they performed this
experiment on the 53 qubit device they
performed this experiment III qubit
device and what was the score that they
got on this cross entropy they got a
score of basically zero point zero zero
two so if you were to plot it on this
this kind of access where zeros uniform
and one that's perfect they ended up
somewhere here right and on the other
hand our evidence for hardness that we
laborious ly went through all this
average case hardness arguments and
stuff to get lives up here like
essentially they got epsilon instead of
1 minus epsilon okay
so there's a gap right so someone
obviously and you know actually what's
interesting is they think that their
score is exponentially decreasing if
they scale their experiment up due to
noise this is just because they're not
they're correcting it but let's let
let's shelve that consideration for now
and let's just ask you know what
evidence is there that getting score
zero point zero zero two is actually
hard right so so there's a gap so how
can you close the gap well they're
basically two approaches that are being
floated around now the first approach is
to make a stronger noise assumption
well if you assume that the output
distribution of your experiment
distancing matrix is say 0.002 times the
ideal one plus you know 0.998
times the maximally mixed date okay so
what is this assumption this assumption
that's kind of saying that the noise
that you're producing is like if you ran
your circuit and you had some errors or
something like that that the resulting
distribution is just like totally
uncorrelated with the ideal distribution
this is one way of thinking of this
assumption and there's some
intuitionists the why this should be
approximately true because this is
coming from some kind of quantum
intuitions that these circuits are very
chaotic or scrambling which causes small
perturbations to kind of spread out as
quickly as they can in the circuit and
kind of deep D correlate things but in
order to directly connect us supremacy
arguments you have to assume this is
true exactly and that's probably not
true as an assumption right like this is
like this is not something that comes
out exactly from any kind of reasonable
noise model but it you know it's
reasonable to think it could it's
approximately true their data kind of
supports this conjecture so that's
that's kind of one way of squaring a
circle but there's another way of
squaring the circle as well and the
other way is basically to make a
different form of hardness assumptions
and this idea goes back to work of
Aronson HN in 2016 the basic idea here
is something like the basic idea is
basically you know can we provide some
evidence that just achieving the score
directly is something that's
computational hard so so all right the
idea is can we directly justify you know
hardness
of achieving a score be on this metric
where B is kind of like your bias away
from the uniform distribution like let's
just let's call this amount beef and the
answer the interesting answer that
Aronson and Chen had is that was
basically yes you can do this but only
if you make kind of additional hardness
assumptions and in particular you have
to assume something oh I'll move this to
center side people can see what's
essentially true is that he defined a
hardness assumption that's called qua
the Quan threshold assumption and it
effectively implies the hardness of
achieving a score
directly there's a kind of relatively
straightforward reduction between these
two things from hardness of it's from
achieving some score to violating cloth
so therefore if you're willing to kind
of make this conjecture these are this
additional complexity conjecture then
instead of kind of running circuitously
through the pH you know all the way to
get back to supremacy arguments you know
maybe you might be able to get there
just directly and since Scott is talking
next I actually don't even have to
explain this to you I can I can let
Scott do this in his own words I should
mention that yeah there's also work of
Aronson and gun recently which extended
this to the the metric sorry 19 extended
this to the you know this linear cross
entropy metric instead of the one they
originally proposed but this is kind of
the the status of the complexity
theoretic evidence you you know if you
want to argue for supremacy the
experiment you have to pay the piper
somewhere you either have to make a
harder stronger noise assumption or you
have to make a stronger hardness
assumption and it's I think there's a
lot of interesting questions here the
work out on to what extent kind of these
are true and hopefully Scott will
provide some comments on this yeah
thanks thanks very much
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah I guess if I think this is coming
from some physics of the device where
you know the states tend to relax down
to the ground state like they do they're
zeros and ones actually of different
energies so this this is like one source
of oh oh I see if you measure oh you're
asking if you measure in the random
local basis let's just turn amplitude
damping into the polarization that's a
good question so you're thinking Shannon
entropy oh yes yes okay yeah yeah okay
so that's the answer here oh sorry sorry
yeah I'll just state what Elizabeth said
she said you know von Neumann entropy is
basis independent so they have different
effects on von Neumann entropy so
therefore it actually is a basis
independent unlike Shannon entropy that
was all those of this college
oh yeah yeah any other questions just a
very naive question of someone not in
the field I'm trying to understand what
verification means here and in subjects
that I'm used to the prover and the
verify are different entities and the
verifier is often not someone with a
vested interest in the proof being true
yes yes exactly
yes yes that's correct
kugel is both to prove her in the
verifiable there's a certain amount of
trust here yes but you can also yeah I
think the way that to view this in this
framework is what they're trying to
achieve here as a form of non
interactive verification so normally
when like for instance you know or
mahadev recent results and and go out
there's have shown that it's possible to
interactively verify some clone
computations where you get to have this
dialogue between asking questions of
some prover you don't trust here they're
trying to achieve some form of
verification that the task was performed
directly but in a much more ambitious
setting where it's not interactive they
literally the you know the prover gives
you samples now you want to check the
prover actually perform this this this
sampling task right so this is a much
harder task which is why we ended up
making more assumptions in order to make
it feasible like we had to assume
something about the prover or something
about the device that's noise had some
certain form and in order to conclude
that that's that this kind of makes
sense I think what one should add that
it would be it would be an easy matter
to have someone else generate the
circuit and send it to Google for the
verification and that probably will be
done for one thing because it's needed
for very certified random this protocol
but only you know talked about later but
it's it's simply that that hasn't been
done yet sure sure yeah thanks yes what
you mentioned is important to
characterize
poised on the system and becomes quite
do it we understand noise increases the
entropy of the distribution not that's a
good question I'm not aware of that
experiment having been done but that's a
great question and well google has
publicly released there a lot of their
data for the samples that they got for
the vise yeah that's a good question I
may have some finite coherence time but
also classical computers are really fast
so maybe that's that that could be
achievable but yeah I don't know off the
top of my head how feasible not this but
but in the case of like why can't we run
your mahadev style verification it's cuz
you know we develop qubits to fit keys
and stuff like this
thanks for your time
[Applause]